welcome back everybody welcome to
another episode of this series
okay we're on okay we finished all these
set one two and three variable operator
and expressions and now we're on to flow
of control we're going to start right at
set one and we're gonna get through as
many of these as we can and I'm probably
gonna stop the video based on a time
limit rather than a certain number I
predict we'll get somewhere till about
7:00 we'll see
all right labs so did bars set one set 2
set 3 we're gonna make a folder called
[ __ ] flow of control don't don't get
that confused that's something else
there's three of them so we'll do set
one stick to our little naming standard
and then we'll go into to Fox that one
and just open up visual studio code on
this folder I suppose so of course we
are using cygwin as our terminal and
here we are let's see we're gonna do a
new file and of course we want a main
before we even get started so I'm just
gonna save on this this is one a plain
text so you if the save even work okay
you know about these save commands on
the programs sometimes they throw random
extension names on it but it's like it
didn't on that okay so and of course a
make file like we did on app last
episode no Flags necessary and we'll
just run it after we build it so that
way we just type make and in our main I
don't know we'll see what we need of
course we are going to need is trained
to do the input output and then we're
going to need a main that returns a 0 at
the end that's pretty standard set up
for any given program
meet an input or a entry area all right
let's do question one any integer is
input by the user we write a program to
find out whether it is an odd number or
an even number okay
so we'll see in a number
int a number it started out as zero so I
have the well you should probably tell
them what we're doing we'll have the
user enter a number okay so we just want
to determine if it's even or odd
so we'll say if a number mod 2 is equal
to zero this means that there's no
remainder left over but after dividing
by then it is even else well we could
say if it's not equal to zero but that's
the only other case that's either equal
to 0 or not so else it is odd let's go
ahead and run this and just confirm that
it works
enter a number that's probably too big
all right but let's say it ends in a
four so it's obviously even and I just
got odd what maybe that number is too
big so I may have overflowed an integer
with this number and that's why I
probably came up with an odd result not
really sure let's just do this into what
happens yeah that's probably what
happened so what I should be doing is
checking limits and making sure the user
entered in an actual integer and not
something invalid like a I don't know
what is this a long long integer it just
overflows the
so that's why you get an incorrect
answer so those are things you got to
watch out for when programming is just
make sure the input is something you can
actually work with all right so there
you go there's the solution there I
don't know if anyone actually wants this
code is I mean it's simple enough that I
don't think so and it's kind of in the
slip you click this little solution you
get their version of it but it's a way
that I can kind of confirm works okay
find the absolute value of a number
entered by the user so we can do this
with the math library see math I think
see math and math thought H I think yeah
I don't know what the difference is
exactly let's just do see math I think
they're approximately the same a number
any number it doesn't really say what
type so maybe it's a float maybe it's a
double maybe it's an integer we'll
assume integer that way we can just use
this again so we'll uncomment that and
we'll just have this up at the top so
get in a number okay so if let's see
absolute value absolute value of number
and we'll start it out of zero and we'll
just say ABS of number equals a mess of
whatever I don't know what I just press
but apparently I opened another visual
studio thing window so there we go
ABS comes from the see math library or
actually come from standard lime so you
can right click on these and go to
definition or press f12 and see where it
comes from this walk was going to take
you into the the header it's in looks
like this actually comes from C standard
live not C math
it might be included through see math
anyway I don't know we we can find out
amps is and we'll just put out the
number and I suppose we want a new line
here okay so let's run this and just
make sure it actually works
yeah it doesn't complain so see Matt
seems to work see Matt must include C
standard library I'm guessing enter any
number let's do negative 50 and the
absolute value of negative 50 is 50 now
this is more likely wanting a double
because they don't mention anything
about what type and number so you would
assume that just a legal number like
this will be fine and there's the
absolute value of it it's just can only
be positive of course it's the
definition of the absolute value okay
write a program to calculate the total
expenses quality and price per item our
input by the user discount 10% is
offered if the expense is more than 5k
all right very good
so let's comment out this I'm actually
gonna just put this down here well clean
up that I don't really need to include
in the video little expenses
item item cost so will prompt for item
cost item cost of course kind of a
clearer little thing up there float or
are we need an integer for the amount
actually we don't want an integer we
want an unsigned integer and this slope
yeah well I don't know I'm not gonna get
to techno we'll just keep a simple item
count
and then we'll do a Const discount
actually okay we multiply it by 0.9 to
get a 10% discount I'm just gonna say
discount
mult or discount multiplier at 5k and
that should take care of it so we got
the item cost in let's just duplicate
this and we want the item count and
we'll just take an item count here and
then down here we're handle the logic
will say if item costs times a double
count is greater than 5000 we should
make this a constant it's work I guess
we want to float discounts level I guess
ball discount level it's gonna be 5,000
we should put it up here and that way we
can just change it if we want like if
you say we're having a deal today now
you only need to buy over a thousand you
could just change this temporarily and
that way you don't have to go modify the
same number all over your code so that's
the point these constants and there we
go
item cost times item count is greater
than discount level then we're gonna say
we could take another variable to hold
the result we'll just we'll do that flow
result or final cost after discount
started out at zero and so in this case
it's going to be this times discount
multiplier
name this multiplier okay
spelling so rather than at 5k because
the five K's this discounted level this
kind of becomes a little redundant weird
at that point alright so there we go
and anything else yes of course what if
they don't have the discount price then
it's just just this you know standard no
discount price parenthesis here are
actually optional and then in we'll just
see out it final cost we could also give
them a little notice in here like you
get a discount and yeah final cost new
line here that's take care of it
I'll just do a make here do a quick
calculation say we're buying I don't
know I big stack of laptops and we're
spending like six mmm 10 grand spending
ten grand and oh wait I'm doing this
wrong okay pretend we're buying I don't
know a bunch of cars in there ten grand
each and we're gonna flip them for
twelve K so we're making money or
something like that
hypothetically and how many of them
we're getting we're getting ten so we
get a discount we end up paying 90,000
for that alright so let's let's do a
more realistic example so here buying
some schoolbooks maybe they're each 150
dollars and if you spend enough at the
bookstore you discount or something and
you're buying six books so you ends up
being 900 bucks no discount but if we
change this discount level to I don't
know like spend more than fifty bucks
and get 10% off you're in
purchase array then it would be
something like this
save 90 bucks there okay well that's
really all I have time for in this
episode and we got through three
questions hope this helps you out and
stick around for more I'll be going
through these okay I can post one a day
or every other day or so and I'd like to
get through every single one of these so
this is gonna be kind of a long I guess
it's not that long I mean once we get to
these a lot of these are just single
projects that's not I don't know that's
not I don't know we'll see alright peace
hi you guys